lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
mostrarles que el ciclo for no es el
único tipo de ciclo que podrían usar
aunque probablemente sea el más común
también pueden usar el ciclo while y tal
vez el ciclo while sea más intuitivo en
el contexto de payton así que voy a
escribir el mismo programa será
exactamente lo mismo pero en lugar de
usar el ciclo for voy a usar el ciclo
while también empezar con la variable
suma igual a cero pero además empezaré
con la variable y igual a cero el ciclo
while no va a definir automáticamente
los valores de i ni va a cambiar
automáticamente los valores de i durante
el ciclo yo lo tengo que hacer pero
lograr el mismo resultado dejaré el
código anterior aquí abajo para que
puedan compararlo y lo marcaré claro
para que no se ejecute porque no quiero
correr la misma cosa dos veces así que
voy a hacer y igual a cero y en caso de
que tengan curiosidad la última vez en
el ciclo for y era una variable válida
solo dentro del ciclo ahora estoy
definiendo la variable y fuera d
ciclo como una variable global la estoy
definiendo en el más alto nivel por lo
que puede ser usada en cualquier parte
del programa ahora aquí voy a definir el
ciclo while y voy a seguir haciendo lo
que había dentro del ciclo mientras si
sea menor que 10 while y menor que 10
recuerden que queremos ejecutar estas
instrucciones mientras si sea igual a 0
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 todos de 0 a 9 sin
incluir 10 así que mientras sí sea menor
que 10 as todo lo que voy a poner en
esta cláusula cuando ya no sea menor que
10 si es igual a 10 ya no se deberá
ejecutar esta cláusula y así lograremos
el mismo comportamiento que aquí abajo y
lo que voy a hacer es decirle suma es
igual a su mamá sí y luego voy a
imprimir suma esto tiene la misma lógica
que el ciclo fort pero voy a tener que
escribir una línea adicional si no
quiero que este ciclo se ejecute
eternamente porque aquí en el ciclo for
cada vez que el programa regresaba
ciclo le asignaba ahí el siguiente
elemento en la lista generada por la
función range aquí arriba no hemos
definido cómo debe cambiar y entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es que en cada ciclo
debemos incrementar el valor de y así
que es igual a y más 1 quiero que se den
cuenta que realmente estas dos cosas son
equivalentes inicializa mos si antes de
entrar al ciclo y es igual a 0 y también
inicializa mos suma también es 0 y
decimos dentro del ciclo suma es igual a
suma más y aquí también imprimimos el
valor de suma y aquí cuando estamos en
el ciclo for a y se le asigna el
siguiente elemento de la lista y en este
ciclo no hay nada que cambie el valor de
y entonces vamos a decir y es igual al
valor previo de i + 1
y esto es equivalente porque cada uno de
los elementos de la lista que genera
range de 10 que definimos en el ciclo
for está incrementado en 1 con relación
al elemento anterior así que podemos
decir cada vez hay y vale 1 más que la
vez anterior y esto producirá el mismo
resultado ahora si no quiere ejecutar
este código si quiero que se quede ahí
para futuras referencias pero no quiero
que el intérprete de payton lo ejecute
podría marcarlo con un signo de gato
como un comentario así que este signo
del gato literalmente le dice al
intérprete ignora todo lo que está aquí
y esto resulta muy útil si tienes código
que no quieres que sea interpretado en
este momento y lo quieres tener ahí para
usarlo más tarde también es útil si le
quieres decir a alguien que esté leyendo
el código a una persona que esté leyendo
el código que hace este código por
ejemplo podríamos escribir un pequeño
comentario aquí
este ciclo while calcula la suma de 0 a
9 incluyendo 9 así que alguien podría
regresar al código y en lugar de tratar
de imaginarse que hace este código
podría leer los comentarios y saber que
esta parte del código calcula la suma de
0 a 9 y pone el resultado y pone cuando
escribimos el signo gato la línea queda
como un comentario si quiero poner otro
comentario debe escribir otro signo gato
aquí el resultado en la variable suma
así que la persona que lea el comentario
sabrá que el resultado está en la
variable suma pero vamos a correr este
programa para que les muestre cómo hay
uno ahora todo lo que está aquí si
corren este texto sin un signo gato la
computadora diría que es todo esto esto
no es código de payton esto es muy útil
para alguien que lee el código y también
se ignora esto que está aquí abajo
voy a poner esto en la línea de arriba
déjenme salvarlo y correrlo
aquí veremos cómo se obtiene exactamente
el mismo resultado recuerdan el
resultado anterior 0 136 pies todo hasta
45 ahora lo voy a correr asumiendo que
no cometí ningún error y obtendremos el
mismo resultado así que el ciclo while
hizo exactamente lo mismo la manera de
definir y es más explícita solo tuvimos
que escribir un poco más de código pero
obtuvimos el mismo resultado